confirmation hearings for Supreme Court
nominee Brett Kavanaugh begin Tuesday if
approved by the Senate Kavanagh will be
president Trump's second appointment to
the High Court and he will solidify its
conservative outlook but justices
political views haven't always played in
such an important role a new book titled
the most dangerous branch inside the
supreme courts assault on the
Constitution argues the court has become
too interventionist and politicized
author David a Kaplan spoke with most of
the current justices as well as past
justices and 65 law clerks who worked at
the court good morning good morning so
when did it start getting so politicized
that we will see on full display on
Tuesday you could argue at different
years of the court in the 20th century
they feared in that direction but I
argue in the book that largely over the
last 50 or 60 years after Brown against
the Board Board of Education and then
during the 1960's in the heyday of the
war in court and and the politicization
is basically presidents going out on the
stump and sang elect me so I can pick
conservative justices or where did it
start what was I think in the first
instance the responsibility lies with
the court the court in too many
different areas has intervened because
it can not because it should so whether
it was abortion in 1973 or Bush v Gore
in 2000 or in gun control or campaign
finance or voting rights in the last 10
years by overruling what the political
branches had done they make the stakes
higher let's separate the process and go
to what what may change here how will
Brett Cavanaugh's appointment change the
direction of the Supreme Court well
replacing Justice Kennedy the court will
certainly move toward the right in a lot
of areas but I would argue that rather
than him becoming the swing justice as
many as many have said it'll be Chief
Justice Roberts it's truly going to
become the Roberts Court and he's the
one to watch I think in coming years and
his regard for the institution and on
occasion his desire to pull the cord out
of the Maelstrom I think
is the best hope for the court I'm not
especially hopeful but I think he's the
best hope
if Cavanaugh became the swing vote that
would be a failure for president Trump
which is to your point in other words
they're picking people now who they know
are gonna vote in a certain more
specific way whereas in the past it was
up for grabs for a lot of the presidents
when they picked correct it's hard to
find another Clarence Thomas and I would
guess that Cavanaugh will not vote as
reliably as Neal Gorsuch David in your
book you say forget the robes maybe the
job should come with tights and a cape
doesn't sound like a compliment though
well I think it's a great gig Justice
Kennedy being the deciding vote in so
many areas gay rights some of the voting
rights cases gun control he ran the
country and if you're running the
country if you're asked to decide these
key social and political areas it's very
hard to say no but Justice Brandeis said
a century ago the hardest thing we do is
not doing the court very infrequently
chooses to stay out and when it does
they out like on partisan gerrymandering
this past spring those are the areas
where they ought to get involved to
regulate I totally agree with you what
are the next big issues that this Court
will decide they will continue there
will be abortion cases there will be
same-sex marriage cases but I think the
key area and this is what's most
important for movement conservatives is
going to be to deregulate what they call
the federal administrative state the
agencies of the federal government
operating under very broad statutes
passed by Congress have vast discretion
and the court for 30 years has deferred
to that I think that's going to stop
Gorsuch already has said in writing that
he disagrees Kavanagh is on record is
disagreeing it's called Chevron
deference and I think taking apart the
power of the SEC the EPA OSHA I think
that's the great grail for conservatives
and I think they may be successful
that's more significant in the long run
than even abortion David Caplin
fascinating book thank you so much
thanks